hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and I just
got this wig in the mail it's for a
Kyrie Kingdom Hearts 3 it's for the
gospel I thought I'd wear it for Roma
last week was fun huh ha ha
thought I'd stay inside this week as to
not get mauled by comic book loving
people I really don't know and I decided
to finally sit down and watch Roma it's
a whole different beast
I think willingly not seeing something
when it's on Netflix if it's in the
theater and you don't get around to it
sure I understand that that's basically
my entire existence but I've been on
Netflix for quite a while I still
haven't sat down and watched it and it
was nominated for all of these things I
think it was enough stuff so I wanted to
talk about what I thought about it if it
was like every man's movie or if it's
just like it's very artistic um I just
kind of how I felt about it
right off the bat it's beautiful I think
some of the shots are God there's Tony
the black-and-white was really striking
it was clearly so beautiful and it's
sitting you're talking about it I feel
like this is just gonna be my episode
from yesterday just carbon copied over
here I just did Godfather Part 2 for
Tamra's never seen and my whole thing
was like it's absolutely beautiful and
clearly a good movie and was it
necessarily for me so
rewind and uh punch it back I should
just just go watch that that's what I
think about Romo it's really good I am
just such I've said this a million times
I'm such a Netflix fan girl I love where
Netflix is taking film I know it's kind
of a controversial subject people aren't
sure they should be nominated or not and
win Oscars and awards and I'm all for it
I think that it's bringing like the art
of filmmaking to a lot more people and
and just like a lot of people are
getting a giant budget to make some
the amazing things it might not
necessarily get them outside of Netflix
world and I think it's also bringing a
lot of really good film to a wider
assortment of people especially
Millennials that might not get out to
the theater I know it's not right for
theaters to and I definitely do not want
theaters to go anywhere obviously but
taking out that crucial thing where
theaters need people to come to them to
survive
I love MIT I think it's really cool but
this is on Netflix I think it's awesome
that an Oscar nominated best film
picture was made for and is on Netflix
that's killer so cool I don't think that
I am the specific audience for this
though I found a lot of enjoyment in it
I think it's really good when things are
happening during it and then also
there's just there's a lot of just
downtime it's one of those movies where
you're just kind of watching people live
their lives and some sad extraordinary
things are happening in those lives but
it just it takes a while to get to the
meat of it after watching the movie I
found out that there's some really
personal ties to the director of this
movie with his life and that some of
these things happened to him or all of
them and I didn't know that and
supposedly I think they're supposed to
make it a little more interesting but
it's such a personal thing but I don't
know I don't think that that's something
you should have to know going in to find
enjoyment of it kind of deal you know
what I mean and again I really think
it's beautiful it's well done the acting
nice got it it's amazing some of the
shots especially at the ocean holy crap
oh there's one where they're at this
farm land and there's all these crops
behind them and they're on this mountain
and it's just gorgeous but it's it's
long and it's boring all right how many
films have penises on Netflix because
this one has full frontal swinging it
around town penis how many
we're penis says how do you delete your
Netflix viewing history hottest sex
scenes and nudity on Netflix Carol is on
Netflix God Carol's amazing Romo isn't
even on this list the movie is based
around Cleo who works for a family in
Mexico City as their servant kind of
deal Cleo gets pregnant and the man that
she gets pregnant with leaves her she
was working for a couple and the husband
leaves the wife in that couple and
honestly it's got total themes of women
power rising above getting through it
finding out who you are taking care of
business
it's really cool I think that kind of
stuff awesome I love love a good rise
above movie the themes aside that that
are told really well though I don't know
guys I just thought it was so boring
instead of Romo I feel like it should
have been named moving on the movie
pretty important story but a little slow
for dum-dums like me the movie pretty
long shots black and white sad the movie
maybe I've just been watching a lot of
sad long long long movies but this just
was not my personal cup of tea again I
see the importance of it I see that it's
absolutely gorgeous incredible work was
put into it and and came out on the
other end very very well done there's
one part where some trees catch on fire
everyone is trying to put them out
there's giant flames everywhere and this
guy in a giant costume comes out and
just start singing and it's very much
the live-action equivalent of the
everything is fine this is fine dog meme
I did like that part the ending is
beautiful and sweet it's really it's
really pretty it's really well acted
choosing between watching this or
watching you know 50 first dates I don't
know why that came to my mind I don't
know I'd probably choose 50 first dates
to be quite honest just it's just this
long and sad and nothing really
happens until it does and then when it
does it's cool but it's long and said
the movie I'm I glad I watched it yes
am I glad it's over with yes okay
exactly the same is my godfather party
review yesterday I would give this god
this is so sad I would give this 5 out
of 5 hair flips for me I just didn't do
it for me
you're so lackluster I know people are
loving this so I hope that I'm not
discouraging anyone who hasn't seen it
yet from seeing it it's on Netflix so
you can watch it literally any time
which is the coolest thing thank you so
much for watching I will see you all
next week with a movie that I'm sure I'm
just going to love us see you then bye
oh it's not done yeah let me just okay
it's right now
beautiful long shots black and white sad
the movie
you